ok freunde der sonne ich war in vegas
und habe mein geld verspielt aber
einfach mal an ich bin eigentlich kein
großer casino fällen zumindest hatte ich
bisher noch nie das bedürfnis gehabt 1
aufzusuchen und hier vielleicht wisst
ich trinke keinen alkohol außer für
wissenschaftliche demonstrationszwecke
deswegen war las vegas jetzt nicht die
stadt meiner wahl aber es lag auf dem
weg unserer route und da dachten hier
das schauen wir uns hier schon mal für
wissenschaftliche demonstrationszwecke
es war anders als es mir vorgestellt
hatte zumindest die casinos also bei
casinos dachte ich bisher immer an und
gewissen glamour so ein bisschen wie man
es in den bond film sieht oder zumindest
mal eine gewisse stimmung an aufregung
anspannung dass leute da ihren gewinnen
hinterher fiebern
aber das war eigentlich eher selten der
fall schätzungsweise 60 bis 80 der
casinos bestanden aus slot machines also
aus diesen einarmigen banditen die auch
bei uns in den kneipen rumstehen
natürlich hat da alles besonders schön
geblinkt aber so richtig glauben oder
aufregend war das nicht wirklich die
stimmung war auf er einsam und traurig
als die leute sagen da alleine vor dem
slot machines geradezu emotionslos und
haben wie automatisiert gespielt als
würden sie fließbandarbeit macht einen
psychologen würde das jetzt nicht
wundern denn slot machines erfüllen
alles was man für eine spielsucht
braucht und auch viele so schmieder
plattform oder handy spiele
funktionieren nach dem prinzip sollten
sie deswegen dachte ich das schaue ich
mir mal etwas genauer an und wage einen
kleinen selbstversuch
[Musik]
erst mal hab ich mir natürlich ein
geltende mit gesetzt 20 dollar
weniger ist langweilig dann wollte ich
das geld in spieltipps umtauschen aber
die brauchte man für slot machines noch
nicht mal das spiel ist ohnehin so
simpel wie es nur geht geld
reinschmeißen knöpfchen drücken und
hebel ziehen dann drehen sich die räder
und wenn ein bestimmtes muster kommt hat
man irgendwas gewonnen man mehr ich nur
an der schieren anzahl des dort machines
sondern auch an deren auf machen dass
diese maschinen das ku klux spiel für
jedermann sein sollen möglichst
verschiedene leute anzusprechen gibt es
noch bis in jeden auch nur erdenklichen
design von klassischen aufmachungen mit
hebel bis hin zu breaking bad oder den
simpsons aber im prinzip sind alle
gleich und ich verliere einfach nur
ziemlich schnell mein geld
dollar
[Musik]
doch ganz viele wie kann das kein gewinn
sein
oder produkt
wir brauchen keinen spaß gemacht ist er
aber beim nächsten automaten sah das
ganze gleich anders aus doch dazu kommt
mir gleich eigentlich ist und dass dort
menschen super langweilig oder eben
frustrierend aber wenn dann mal doch ein
gewinn rausspringt freut man sich trotz
sehen und wie das zu einer spielsucht
führen kann
das hängt mit ganz grundlegenden
funktionsprinzipien unseres gehirns
zusammen habt ihr es gemerkt gehirn
nicht gehirn gehirn lerne dazu an
trainierte essverhalten konditionierung
wir kommen jetzt zu grundlegender
verhaltenspsychologie denn mein
verhalten belohnt wird erhöht sich die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass sich dieses
behalten wiederhole heißt sobald ich
irgendwas gewinne bei der slot maschinen
belohnung ziehe ich den hebel
wahrscheinlich nochmal mit hilfe von
belohnungen lässt sich verhalten
antrainieren wir werden konditioniert
dazu den hebel zu ziehen oder das
knöpfchen zu drücken was kommt jetzt
noch was wichtiges hinzu nämlich wir
wissen nicht wann die nächste belohnung
kommt könnte beim nächsten knopfdruck
sein könnte auch erst beim hundertsten
sein und wir wissen nicht wie hoch die
belohnung ist es könnte ein gewinn von
10 cent sein oder von 10.000 dollar die
belohnung ist nicht voraussagbar
und genau das macht besonders wichtig
die überraschung macht
verhaltenspsychologie und suchtpotenzial
wurden zunächst an tieren untersucht
werden zum beispiel die berühmten
experimente des psychologen bier skinner
und tauben stellt euch folgendes
experiment vor glauben und die kriegen
futter immer wenn sie einen signal auf
der scheibe an picken also quasi immer
wenn sie ein knöpfchen drücken dadurch
werden die kirche konditioniert die
scheibe zu kicken das verhalten wird zu
einem wiederkehrenden falten weil es mit
futter belohnt wird aber dieses
verhalten kann sehr unterschiedlich
ausfallen
je nachdem wie man die belohnung
gestaltet man kann zum beispiel der
taube nicht jedes mal futter geben wenn
sie das knöpfchen drückt sondern nur
manchmal
das heißt die anzahl der drucker bevor
sie futter bekommt wird jede runde nach
zufallsprinzip geändert die taube weiß
also nicht wie oft sie drücken muss um
belohnt zu werden
dieses belohnung schema nennt sich der
jubel
ratio und sorgt dafür dass die tauben
viel heftiger auf das knöpfchen abgehen
und bevor jetzt sagt ja sie kriegen ja
jetzt auch seltener futter kein wunder
dass sie mehr abgehen
ganz so einfach ist es nicht sagen wir
wir haben zwei verschiedene versuch
settings setting 1 die taube muss
zehnmal knöpfchen drücken um futter zu
bekommen also immer zehnmal setting zwei
die taube muss verschiedene aufpicken
anzahl zufällig also serie bereits aber
im schnitt kommen wir auch auf 10 x
tekken pro belohnung das heißt am ende
kriegt sie in setting 1 und 2 gleich
viel futter wenn man die zwei jetzt
vergleicht dann sieht man auch hier dass
die tauben in setting zwei heftige
abgehen als in sitting 1 zum beispiel
machen die tauben in setting 1 nach
jeder belohnung also nach dem futter
eine kurze pause
das machen die hier nicht immer hier
machen wir direkt weiter und mehr noch
wenn meine kaum die wahl lässt
von welchem apparat sie sich futter
holen wollen von so einem der nach
setting 1 läuft außer immer regelmäßig
oder nach einem dating 2 läuft also
zufällig dann wählen die tauben lieber
das zu preis setting tauben fahren also
auf unvorhersehbare belohnungen ab und
wir menschen auch dass es inzwischen gut
untersucht wobei bf skinner schon damals
den bezug zwischen tauben und spielsucht
bzw
verschiedenes herstellte die fähigkeit
aus belohnungen zu lernen hängt bei
tauben wie menschen von dem
neurotransmitter dopamin
dieses molekül wird in meinem gehirn
ausgeschüttet so bald etwas passiert
dass ich als belohnt empfinde bei der
taube sind die leckeren kölner bei mir
ist es der jackpot in vegas unsere
gehirnzellen haben verbindungen die
sogenannten synapsen und die stärke
dieser verbindung die kann dopamin ende
in diesem fall führt es dazu dass das
verhalten das sich kurz vor der
belohnung aus geführt habe dass das
gestärkt wird und so kriege ich los
dieses verhalten zu wiederholen also zum
beispiel noch mal aufs knöpfchen zu
drücken
diese grundfunktionen unseres gehirns
werden auch in anderen bereichen
geschickt ausgenutzt kostenlose handy
spiele zum beispiel leben nicht nur von
werbung sondern auch von in app käufen
deswegen sind diese spiele kann die
karte zum beispiel so gestaltet dass es
unendlich viele level gibt die man
hochklettern kann
und mit jedem abgeschlossenen level ist
das ein belohnungs gefühl dopamin wird
ausgeschüttet und man möchte es immer
wieder haben so sehr dass wir mal
stecken bleibt dazu bereit ist
vielleicht dann doch mal geld auszugeben
um irgendwelche booster zu kaufen um
eben ins nächste level zu kommen und
auch das prinzip der unbekannten
belohnung sieht man hier ganz oft in
martin handy spielen kann zum beispiel
mystery booster boxen kaufen in
irgendwelchen special sales wo man gar
nicht genau weiß was man für sein geld
bekommen und auch social media
funktioniert nach dem prinzip also never
ending newstead wird immer wieder
aktualisiert man kann stundenlang
scrollen selbst will nichts interessant
dabei ist hat man immer noch die
hoffnung dass der nächste post
vielleicht lustig ist oder vielleicht
der übernächste oder vielleicht auch der
hundertste slot machines und spiele nach
demselben prinzip sind die glücksspiele
die am wichtigsten machen
deswegen ist es wahrscheinlich gar nicht
so erstaunlich dass slot machines die
casinos in vegas so dominieren ich hatte
auch den eindruck dass da die meisten
stammkunden sitzen
es waren leer aber des läufers saßen
schon leute ich weiß nicht auf die schon
da saß oder noch da saßen früher waren
slot machines aber noch nicht ganz so
dick wie heute früher gab es zum
beispiel nur eine gewinn zeile und wände
halt dreimal die kirche kam hat man was
geworden das waren dann seltenere
größere gewinne heute setzen die macher
auf unzählige verschiedene
gewinnkombinationen auch viele kleine
gewinne statt ab und zu was größeres das
prinzip der kleinen gewinne demonstriert
mir diese maschine wenn es die
verschiedenen mich enttäuscht
dauert lange bis es blinkt und ich was
gewonnen habe 15 cent aber dafür dauert
es nicht lange bis ich wieder was
gewinnen
wichtig sind gar nicht so wenig dafür
dass ich immer nur 24 cents setze ich
muss sagen hier macht ist tatsächlich
etwas spaß beim spiel halt auch nicht so
schnell vorbei ist und so richtig freue
ich mich als ich bei der reinen nicht
letzten runde noch einmal 60 cent
gewinne was das spiel dann wieder um
mehrere runden verlängert natürlich weiß
ich dass die sind gewinne lächerlich
klein sind aber dopamin wird trotzdem
ausgeschüttet und diese suchtpotenzial
zieht den leuten das geld aus der tasche
denn verlust garantiert casinos sind ja
ein geschäftsmodell lieber einen
glücksspielen wird hier sicher gestellt
dass am ende des tages mehr geld in die
maschine rhein geflossen ist als wieder
rauskommt wäre die slot machine fair und
ich würde 100 mal einen dollar setzen
cam durchschnittlich 100 dollar auch
wieder rausgekommen aber nur 80 prozent
wieder zurück oder 90 prozent je nach
casino gerät decken römer hier nicht
verlieren nicht alles komplett
aber gerade die ständigen gewinne
motivieren mich dazu immer weiter zu
spielen und je länger ich spiele desto
ärmer werde ich
dollar verschmiert
das ganze hat mit maschinen wechseln und
herumlaufen und so weiter vielleicht
eine viertelstunde gedauert und so geht
es letztendlich allen spielern doch
sucht prinzip funktioniert trotzdem und
viele kommen immer wieder zurück um ihr
geld loszuwerden also hat mich jetzt die
spielsucht gepackt obwohl diese
belohnungssysteme unsere grundlegende
psyche ansprechen haben verschiedene
menschen dennoch verschiedenen großes
suchtpotenzial
zum beispiel ist es nicht selten dass
menschen nach einem traumatischen
erlebnis einer spielsucht verfallen mich
hat dieses experiment jetzt eher
frustriert und ich nicht das gefühl dass
ich der spielsucht ein kleines
schrittchen näher gekommen bin
zumindest hatte ich keine lust jetzt
nochmal zu spielen und mein erster
casinobesuch wir doch erst mal mein
letzter sein und das ist auch das
einzige was ich euch raten kann fand das
gar nicht damit an aber die 20 cent
gewinnen die habe ich mir natürlich nur
auszahlen lassen
[Musik]
was es mit euch habt ihr erfahrungen mit
kasinos oder glücksspiel oder gibt es
irgend ein handyspiel nach dem gesicht
ich seit ich meine kenny chesney jetzt
auch schon ein bisschen älter es gibt
doch bestimmt was neues schreibt es in
die kommentare wir sehen uns nächste
woche und das solltet ihr nicht
verpassen denn es gibt ein major in
mainz mit soviel berate ich schon mal
wir sehen uns bis dahin bleibt sicher
wenn er das video
aufhören die menschen
also bisher bin ich eine sehr frustriert
nicht was ich recherchiert habe
es sind kleine
darüber freuen entscheiden
nichts geworden
spaß macht das spaß
wir müssen jetzt gepackt wir müssen
gewinnen